Peter Katz, Story Driven CEO: Do they get
me hyped because you have to be hyped to go
through all the different it's kind of like
Indiana Jones or a big heist to get these
deals going you have to do whatever it takes.
You have to put yourself out there so you
have to have that fire in you and great clients
light that fire in me.
Film Courage: What do you promise your writers?
Peter: I don't looking necessarily… there's
a template because I do think each writer
is unique and has unique sense of priorities
for what they want. But I guess when you look
at it maybe not necessarily a promise it's
what I guess an expectation of a manager is
that they need to be able to work together
and look at material and figure out which
concepts may be more viable and develop them
and then take them out to market and doing
these things are very important to any writer
and so it's not just putting somebody in a
room because sometimes writer just go have
a meeting but why is the meet why are you
having the meeting is this person specifically
looking for this kind of material I think
that's also important it's not just oh let's
just show off here have a meeting here because
there's some pointless meetings in Hollywood
I'll tell you there's meetings that you'll
leave with they'll give you a water bottle
and you’re I got a water bottle and that
was it if I have a meeting I want my clients
to get paid at some point from that relationship
I want to make sure that it's the right person
at the right time then maybe it's not now
but six months from now I get a phone call
from this producer and says I'm absolutely
looking for that writer looking for that kind
of writer that I met so there is a there needs
to be pragmatism from the beginning of development
of an idea to taking it out to establishing
a network in the industry that you're just
arbitrarily doing something but I would never
just go just write something or just meet
somebody it needs to have a purpose so that's
a lot of my goal is working in conjunction
with a client sometimes it means also working
with an agent and a lawyer or a publicist
there's different collaborators that can get
pulled into a team and each team's unique
and for me I want to make sure that I have
a great relationship and shorthand with all
the members of the team.
Film Courage: What do you not promise your
writers?
Peter: I never set a frame this is going to
be this or it's not going to be that I kind
of keep it flexible but what I could say is
this I’m a passionate person I believe in
your work I'm going to do whatever it takes
to advance our agendas that's just to build
either building a viable business out of a
client or if a client is already a business
how to maintain that business and make it
bigger and so do they have to exclusively
work with you you make them sign something
where they would only work with you I don't
necessarily look at it exclusively so I work
with agents all the time I love collaborating
with the right agent so I could have an agent
that I have a good relationship with and then
they have qualities that they bring to the
table so for me it's not proprietary over
the client I want to get the right agent ideally
the right lawyer and then some clients might
want to publish this maybe specifically for
film festivals or one of the movies movies
get released work with the publicist so to
me it's almost each client is its own unique
business that we're working together so a
manager an agent could have multiple businesses
running out once it's different than being
a producer where you have a movie mostly you
make the film it gets released everyone makes
their money it's done unless it's a franchise
or spin-offs but let's say it's just a normal
film a client is a is going to always be building
new opportunities and potentially you could
take assignments or sell something so there's
so many more variables as an individual than
it then it's just a one-off movie that gets
released so to me it's just being receptive
to those needs and seeing opportunities as
they present themselves what do you look for
in a client I think that the client that I
want to work with connects my taste so I think
that anybody in this industry just because
if let's say a manager an agent passes on
them it doesn't mean that they're not amazingly
talented it just means that maybe that rep
has different tastes my tastes are not it's
not math it's not this indisputable thing
it's more this is a fact is this person good
or bad it's more I read the script I watch
a movie and then I'm passionate it moves me
emotionally because I do think that we live
in a living's hard how just the day to day
it's just you get apathetic you had a hard
day or whatever and sometimes you're just
all right this day felt the next day and you're
whatever but if you read a really good script
it stops time you're oh my gosh I'm feeling
this writer's voice it just is moving me and
that's the kind of client that I want is that
they move me specifically I might they might
not remove the other manager at this company
and that's fine or vice versa there might
be a totally viable client that doesn't excite
me but another manager loves working with
them so it's very specific to my curation
is going to be that do they get me hyped because
you have to be hyped to go through all the
different it's kind of Indiana Jones or a
big heist it's to get these deals going you
have to do whatever it takes you have to put
yourself out there so you have to have that
fire in you and the great clients light that
fire in me and now beyond that aspect of it
we also need to have a good back and forth
it needs to be hey we're working together
because we like each other enough it doesn't
mean oh my gosh this client is exactly me
I’m not looking for me I don't care if they're
different backgrounds everything to me it's
not I'm looking for I want to rap myself I
want to write voices that excite me because
I've never seen anything it that's what gets
me into it so so I'm just mean that we have
a relationship that is really about listening
to each other and respecting each other and
open to different ideas and once you have
the the work that makes you get moving and
get going and making making things happen
plus you have that partnership where we could
adapt to we're saying the chaos of of anything
that is thrown at us that's the ideal client
for me when you say chaos what kind of chaos
could come up I think that the entertainment
industry is unlike a lot of other fields because
how quickly it mutates there's always new
opportunities but at the same time there could
be new risks so which you think let's say
from the 90’s may not work now or what industry
it's just everything's rapidly changing which
is why it's also kind of fun because you're
who knows what's happening next but it just
means you just have to keep your eye out there
and see what's happening and be tapped in
to to these innovations and that's to me what
the chaos is it's and that bleeds into your
day-to-day too so on a macro level there's
all these shifts but it creates ripple effects
that you feel immediately and that's what
you have to be okay with you're not getting
into this business because you're you want
something that's very stagnant you get into
it because you want something that could just
be super compelling all the time because you
don't know what's going to happen next and
to me that's why I'm excited about my work
do you to be kept guessing sometimes it's
not that I want to be kept guessing is that
I've always been interested in media and technology
I've always been interested in movies how
they're distributed how they're monetized
so for me I love just seeing I love seeing
this world shifting and seeing new new possibilities
so when you see Netflix and suddenly you watch
a limited series that Queen's Gambit on you're
wow that's possible I haven't seen a limited
series that before so to me it's about getting
inspired I'm very open to finding inspiration
as new projects get made and new businesses
advance and then you could see an opportunity
podcasting is starting to blow up and it's
so much fun to also manage some podcasters
and work with them and work on those unique
deals that are starting to surface from major
companies so that's what gets me and it's
the inspiration around these new new innovations
that's what gets me interested in the next
one and you had a podcast yourself yeah I
had a podcast called Hollywood 2.0 and it
was basically a podcast that covered the intersection
of media and technology and we talked to everybody
from people create virtual reality people
created distribution companies digitally and
it was exciting to just see what the trailblazers
are doing and did you notice I don't know
what year you started that by the way I don't
remember exactly when I started I did it for
a few years and before I was a manager and
it just was it was also fun it was seeing
it and then seeing how other people are experiencing
the industry and and where it's going because
the people I talked to were the ones that
are always on the bleeding edge of innovation
so somebody could be from the Sundance innovation
at Sundance studying virtual reality and innovation
and that speaker could be coming from that
point of view so to me it was fun to watch
these businesses evolve and some of them actually
one of them got acquired one of the the the
founders sold a a podcast company so it was
really cool to see the acquisition and see
money move into the podcast space and that
was the early sign of the signals of things
that come so yeah I really enjoyed it in a
lot of ways I keep doing it through my work
by seeing maybe a movie that I have a client
makes could also be a tv show how do you spin
off a film into tv and that's starting to
become you start seeing that people are thinking
that way you'll see a show that will be starting
as a movie and recently there was a great
film that's on Netflix called The Hater and
that was sold to HBO as a TV show pitch so
that's something that's really unique to me
I'm wow you could do that so that's why I
got inspired but it's what if I got one of
my clients movies facility that kind of thing
always keeps me keeps me thinking.
Question For The Viewers:
What insights did you gain from this video?